bonsoir nous sommes je disais 10 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition l'association évinoise hf
prévention et un ssd france ans une
nouvelle version de l'application tube
le premier portail numérique de la santé
sexuelle
le point dans notre chronique santé avec
william l aujourd'hui l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
organisée la sixième édition de la
journée de l'entrepreneuriat cette année
le thème était l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin un moyen de faire découvrir ce
monde et ses codes aux étudiants et le
haras des bréviaires est le seul art and
national d'île de france le site devrait
être repris pour acheter
qu'en est il aujourd'hui de sa situation
dans le département le plus cavalier de
france pour nous en parler ce soir
deux invités jérôme singer responsable
de l'attelage et correspondant
patrimoine et marion lhote directrice du
haras et opération de sensibilisation à
destination des motards ce matin sur la
route nationale 10 entre trappe élise
essarts-le-roi une unité de sécurité
routière de la police nationale étaient
présentes à l'origine de cette opération
la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique des yvelines
l'objectif n'était non pas de verbaliser
les cyclomoteurs mais de les
sensibiliser à l'expérimentation et aux
règles de la circulation inter files
mise en place depuis le mois de février
2016 cette pratique implique de
respecter certaines règles
la circulation inter files est limitée à
50 km heure en ville et reste interdite
en ville et sur les routes non séparées
par un terre-plein central
on écoute tout de suite les réactions
d'un motard ainsi que celle de frédéric
frémont commissaire de police en charge
de l'opération
ce une bonne chose
c'est bien de de faire prendre
conscience aux motards qu'il faut faire
attention même en passant entre les
voitures
moi je pense surtout que c'est c'est
plutôt aux autres usagers
les prévenir que maintenant enfin les
motards ont le droit
selon certaines
disposition de pouvoir passer entre les
files de voitures on est là aujourd'hui
pour leur rappeler que les remonte et
ils se font dans des conditions assez
précises leur rappeler aussi que dans ce
département
nous avons certes une baisse du nombre
global des morts depuis deux ans et
c'est une grande satisfaction
nous avons encore un ratio de 45 % des
tués qui sont des tués qui étaient des
conducteurs de deux roues
donc on profite cette circulation inter
files à l'essai pour rappeler aussi que
dans ce département
les motocyclistes sont des usagers
vulnérables et en 2015 24 personnes ont
été tuées sur les routes du département
et parmi elles on dénombre onze motards
la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique des yvelines
réorganisera ce type d'opération dès le
printemps est aujourd'hui l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
organisée la sixième édition de la
journée entrepreneuriat étudiant
concours de pitch témoignages de jeunes
stars torpeur start up et repartons
speed-meeting autant d'occasions qui ont
permis aux étudiants de découvrir
l'entrepreneuriat et de tester leurs
idées de création d'entreprise
retour sur cette journée spéciale à
université avec fanny bourdillon
entreprendre un défi difficile à relever
pour les étudiants mais encore plus pour
les étudiantes
aujourd'hui seulement 30 % des créateurs
d'entreprise sont des femmes alors pour
pallier ce déficit lui vs qu organisé
aujourd'hui sa journée annuelle
entrepreneuriat étudiant sous un angle
bien particulier l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin pour les aider à se lancer ici à
l'université on organise un certain
nombre donc d'ateliers sûr sûr sûr cette
journée pour notamment
lever l'ensemble des difficultés liées à
la méconnaissance du métier d'entreprise
monter une entreprise
il ya beaucoup de législation il ya il
faut savoir aussi monter son business
plan il faut savoir rencontrer
c'est enfin monter ces nouveaux contrats
rencontrer ses futurs acheteurs ya tout
un aspect réseau et c'est là dessus
qu'on essaie de les aider donc ici à
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs en activité qui
sont là pour créer des liens créer des
réseaux potentiel et en particulier un
sens nombre d'entrepreneurs féminine
avocate coach sportive ou encore
graphistes les entrepreneurs féminine
représente tous les domaines d'activité
sophie travaille dans la finance elle
s'est mise à son compte il y a huit ans
et aujourd'hui elle veut montrer
l'exemple
il faut oser c'est con ça que je suis là
aujourd'hui pour dire aux entrepreneurs
ceux qui ont envie de se lancer sur toi
celle qui a envie de se lancer qu'il
faut y aller qui faisait que
effectivement créer son entreprise c'est
pas facile qui a plein d'embûches mais
qui a aussi plein plein de systèmes pour
aider il ya des structures qui
accompagnent la création d'entreprise il
ya des côtes ce qui accompagnait aussi
cette année 80 projets étudiants
participent à des concours de pitch où
l'on teste les idées de création
d'entreprise sophie échanges avec ce
groupe d'étudiants en l3 et en profite
pour donner quelques conseils et trois
minutes ça fait quoi
ça fait super court il faut s'entraîner
avec un timer parce que sinon on a à
peine commencé la phrase nous dans la
catégorie jeune pousse donc je crois
qu'il ya six groupes et c'est juste un
petit pitch de 32 trains minutes pour
présenter un projet trois minutes pour
convaincre et de nombreux prix a
remporté cette année le prix de
l'entrepreneuriat féminin devrait
encourager les créatrices de demandes
économie toujours comment lancer et
créer rapidement son entreprise la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie des
yvelines vient de mettre en place un
nouveau dispositif qui s'appelle la
securitate l'objectif aider les futurs
chefs d'entreprise à formaliser leur
statut et à procéder à l'enregistrement
de leur société dans de très brefs
délais et cela en toute sécurité
les explications avec fanny bronner être
perdus au milieu des démarches
administratives
reynaldo connaît bien il y a dix ans il
a lancé son entreprise de bâtiment au
portugal aujourd'hui il souhaite
installer une filiale dans les yvelines
avec deux de ses salariés il est venu
demander de l'aide à la cci en portugal
et en france c'est la même chose la
difficulté l'avocat si c'est la même
chose c'est pour ça que j'ai passées ici
on sait y faire plus rapide la chose
plus de rapidité et plus de sécurité
c'est l'objectif du nouveau dispositif
sécuritaire mis en place par le centre
de formalités des entreprises
ici on suit un projet de sa création
jusqu'au 3 ans de la société
pourquoi ces trois ans parce que les
statistiques montrent que pratiquement
trois entreprises sur cinq ne tiennent
pas trois ans ça peut être
éventuellement un projet au moins
d'immatriculations qui a mal été
formalisé mais c'est aussi un projet qui
s'est mal développée donc cet
accompagnement logiquement au bout de
trois ans vous êtes en mesure d'avoir
une entreprise pérenne l'étape la plus
importante dans la création d'entreprise
c'est choisir et formaliser ses statuts
c'est là que le dispositif sécuritaire
intervient le service coûte 450 euros
hors taxes aux entrepreneurs c'est
finalement une formule clé en main que
l'on propose à nos porteurs de projet
qui consiste
à trois rendez vous successifs qui
peuvent être réalisées assez rapidement
en 72 heures et on va créer une
entreprise sécurisé par un de nos
experts en droit fiscal et social et
procéder tout suivi de l'immatriculation
du cadre supérieur aux commerçants
ambulants
le cfe accueille tous les profils plus
de 500 entrepreneurs passent les portes
de ce centre chaque mois ok ok c'est bon
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique du jeudi pas de sport ce soir
c'est william qui nous rejoint pour une
chronique à sa santé aujourd'hui vous
allez nous parler une prévention oui
bonsoir florane car ce matin à paris
c'était le lancement de la nouvelle
application tup l'application mobile
lancée par msd france en partenariat
avec hf prévention qui permet de
localiser les points de vente de moyens
de contraception donc tubes pour trouver
un préservatif près de chez soi grâce à
son smartphone alors comment ça marche
c'est très simple on se géolocalise là
une carte apparaît et on voit les
différents points de vente que ce soit
un magasin un point presse ou encore les
petits distributeurs que l'on trouve à
l'extérieur des pharmacies en tout c'est
plus de 52000 points de vente de
distribution qui sont répertoriés dans
toute la france tu qu'une application
donc très utile qui malgré son support
n'est pas destiné qu'aux jeunes se
rendre compte qu'on a pas de préservatif
au dernier moment ça peut arriver à tout
le monde
d'ailleurs les jeunes on est quand même
allé leur poser la question est ce que
ça leur est déjà arrivé et comment ils
ont fait non non pas du tout mais non
non ça va pas arriver alors ça m'est
arrivé une fois et j'ai la chance
d'habiter pas loin d'une pharmacie en
journée mais il y avait une petite borne
à l'extérieur éventuellement pour en
acheter dans la nuit aussi donc j'ai la
chance d'avoir ça à côté de chez moi je
suis en train de me rappelez moi je
crois que ça m'ait jamais vraiment
arrivé
ouais voilà quelqu'un de frais voyant
mais sinon comment j'ai fait je pense
que j'ai pas fait et simplement
je me souviens qu'une fois je cherchais
des préservatifs et je voulais des
trouver des distributeurs mais y en
avait pas et du coup je les enfants
machine mais voilà deux heures du matin
non ça par contre ce genre de situation
ça m'est jamais arrivé non la pilule du
lendemain ça m'est déjà arrivé au cas où
non sans préservatif faire sans
plusieurs motifs ensuite pense de se
dire on consomme plus voilà ça n'a pas
l'air d'être la meilleure solution ces
dernières répondent alors non c'est
certain ça ne l'est pas et la pilule du
lendemain pour éviter les infections
sexuellement transmissibles n'a
malheureusement toujours pas été inventé
ça prouve qu'il ya toujours besoin de
faire de la prévention
en ce qui concerne le port du
préservatif c'est donc l'association hf
prévention qui s'occupe de l'application
cube qui en est déjà à plus de cent
mille téléchargements mobiles à chaque
prévention qui je le rappelle est déjà
très présente sur le secteur de la lutte
en fin de la lutte contre les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles excusez moi
on se rappelle évidemment virus oif à
paris en octobre dernier vers histoire
c'est un jeu interactif géant qui se
présentait sous la forme d'un laser game
les participants enfilé soul ont filé
une tenue et devait à l'aide de leur
pistolet détruire le virus du sida
le jeu était resté durant cinq jours
place de la bastille et ça avait été un
réel succès change games est le nom du
concept de ce type de jeu grandeur
nature qui avait importé des états unis
et c'était donc une grande première en
france peut dire c'est ça de se mettre à
la page
exactement et c'est justement ça
l'objectif de l'application tube toucher
le plus grand nombre de personnes avec
des nouvelles technologies parce que tu
ben c'est pas seulement un moyen de
localiser les points de vente de
préservatifs tue c'est aussi un moyen de
trouver les centres de dépistage prix de
chez vous mais aussi d'obtenir des
informations sur les différentes ist
écoutez plutôt germandrée le directeur
de hf prévention qui vous en parlera
mieux que moi la version 2 est basé
beaucoup plus sur la santé sexuelle donc
des gens à l'image des nouveaux centres
de dépistage qui propose plein de
consultation sur la santé sexuelle
tu peux effectivement référence est la
seule source de référencement de toutes
ces innovations en prévention santé
on peut trouver des préservatifs qu'ils
soient gratuits ou payants on peut
retrouver des plannings familiaux
on peut trouver des centres de
planification notamment dans les
yvelines
on peut connaître les horaires on peut
effectivement avoir les centres de
dépistage
bref c'est la boîte à outils de la santé
sexuelle est un outil comme celle ci est
vraiment nécessaire aujourd'hui on parle
déjà beaucoup de prévention notamment
concernant les daaf
oui on en parle mais c'est vrai ça ne
suffit pas aujourd'hui l'incidence de
l'infection par le vih n'augmente pas
mais ne faiblit pas non plus c'est dû à
plusieurs facteurs notamment le fait que
le virus ne fait plus peur maintenant
les gens savent que l'on peut continuer
à vivre normalement en étant
séropositive si l'on suit un traitement
il ya aussi le regard que l'on porte sur
la maladie dans les années 80 il y avait
de la compassion pour les gens qui
étaient atteints du virus du sida
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup plus de honte
et un sentiment de gêne par rapport à ce
virus pardon excusez moi il faut le
rappeler c'est un des objectifs de
l'application que des solutions de
gestion de risque et de risque sexuel
existe et atténuer ou font disparaître
le risque d'infection au virus
si elles sont adoptées attend ici
l'application tube offre un moyen
d'accès rapide et anonyme aux
informations relatives à ces solutions
une dernière étude montre que 48 % des
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans n'ont jamais avoue
n'avoir jamais effectuée avec un
dépistage au vih
il faut aussi casser les idées reçues
car 53% des contaminations sont dus à
des rapports hétérosexuels
on parle aussi des applications de
rencontres qui ont favorisé la
propagation des ist en zone urbaine le
fait aujourd'hui que les jeunes
utilisent des applications mobiles pour
se géolocaliser et pour avoir
effectivement des rencontres un peu
facile un peu rapide
ils ne vont pas forcément avoir le
réflexe de la prévention ces
applications sont pas faites pour ça
c'est des applications qui vont
permettre à des gens de pouvoir trouver
donc d'autres personnes pour faire des
rencontres
il était important d'avoir une
application qui l a été le pendant de sa
équivalait pouvoir donc présenté de la
publicité sur ses premières applications
pour les diriger vers tube
trouver des préservatifs et des lieux de
dépistage ça permet effectivement d'être
présent sur des nouveaux médias sur des
médias qui sont dans les poches des
média connecté c'est pour ça qu'on a une
page facebook
c'est pour ça qu'on a un compte twitter
parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui la
cible des gens qui sont les plus
contaminés c les moins de 25 ans mais
c'est aussi les plus de 45 ans alors
voila tu pues l'application qui se
destine à tous hommes et femmes parce
que lorsqu'on parle points de vente de
préservatifs on parle points de vente de
préservatifs masculins comme féminins
tube c'est aussi des fiches sur les
différentes ist et les moyens de
contraception mais aussi sur les vaccins
avec un agenda des événements liés au
dépistage et à la prévention comme les
opérations sortez couverts et une minute
pour savoir mais aussi localiser le cube
trucks le camion itinérant de la chef
prévention qui promeut l'application en
faisant le tour des villes d'île de
france en ce moment pour 10 pour
distribuer conseil et préservatifs et
bien j'espère que vous ne préviendrai
williams lorsqu'elle passera à 50 ans
roule bien oui et n'hésitez pas à y
aller chercher préservatifs et surtout
d'en porter parce que n'oubliez pas ce à
cause de ça qu'on d'après perdu freddie
mercury mais aussi qu'on a eus vu naître
beaucoup d'autres artistes comme aurait
pu éviter
merci williams et les journées andy fac
2016 se poursuivent l'événement annuel
permet de mobiliser et de sensibiliser à
la problématique du handicap étudiants à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
l'accent a notamment été porté sur le
sport mercredi
découverte du babington en fauteuil mais
aussi du showdown un dérivé du tennis de
table pour les personnes malvoyantes
avec ce sujet signé wilfried richie et
qui a mis en vers
un simple le grelot pour localiser la
balle françois aveugle de naissance n'a
que ce léger tassement comme repère cela
fait trois ans qu'il pratique ce dérivé
du tennis de table le showdown
je fais des sensibilisations pour parler
du handicap vois ça ne disait
associations hors du mot créé un petit
peu ce qu'on peut faire quand on voit
pas et puis pour casser un petit peu les
idées reçues des gens qui pensent que
quand on voit pas on peut rien faire
piloté par le service d'accompagnement
des étudiants handicapés de l'université
de versailles saint quentin les journées
andy fac sont donc l'occasion de prendre
conscience des conséquences qu'implique
le handicap et les moyens déployés pour
le compenser avec le chemin de la
concentration doit être optimum
c'est un jeu très intéressant parce
qu'il peut être aussi un jeu de partage
les personnes qui sont voyante se met un
masque sur les yeux se met dans la
situation d'une personne non voyante et
peuvent jouer ajoute en un peu plus de
difficulté pour qu'elles apprennent
parce que tout se passe avec l'audition
autres sports qui permettent aux valides
et aux personnes en situation de
handicap de se retrouver le badminton
ça change la la vision qu'on a des
personnes qui sont dans cette situation
ce qu'on comprend vraiment mieux même si
on il faudrait tous les jours dans ce
fauteuil roulant pour vraiment
comprendre ce qu'ils vivent
ça nous permet une approche une approche
différente et une vision différente de
ce qu'ils endurent tous les jours le
sport mais aussi le théâtre était à
l'honneur pour cette opération en dix
fac au quotidien des associations
étudiantes interviennent aussi pour que
la démarche se poursuivre au delà de ces
quelques jours et je vous disais en
titre le haras des bréviaires est le
seul haras national d'île de france et
il se trouve dans les yvelines
le conseil général son propriétaire l'a
mis en vente en 2014 depuis beaucoup
d'éléments ont été dits mais le haras
n'a pas encore trouvé de repreneur pour
nous en parler ce soir avec nous deux
invités jérôme à singer responsable de
l'attelage et correspond au patrimoine
et marion lhote directrice du haras
bonsoir à vous deux et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors tout d'abord j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur les stations du haras le
conseil général était propriétaire
depuis 1973 il a lancé un appel à
projets pour l'achat ou la reprise en
gestion du site en décembre 2015 les
candidats avaient jusqu'à fin février
2015 pour se déclarer
qu'en est il aujourd'hui mais
effectivement nous aussi nous sommes
dans la tente en fait du résultat de
l'appel d'offres qui a été effectivement
effectué par le conseil départemental
alors plusieurs personnalités s'étaient
opposés à la vente
est-ce que vous même vous opposer à
cette banque la comment ça se passe un
petit peu dur autre côté dans le à ce
niveau là donc le haras national dépend
de l'institut français du cheval et de
l'équitation et nous on n'a pas vocation
à prendre parti dans la vente ou pas du
haut rhin nous on est actuellement
gestionnaire du site au travers d'une
autorisation d'occupation en fait et
donc on gère le site et il existe
aujourd'hui plusieurs partenaires en
fait que sont actuellement le cref le cd
des yvelines mais aussi la coopérative
comédien et le poste à cheval
on s'était essentiellement un problème
de subventions c'est un problème de
gestion globale mais là c'est une
décision qui regarde complètement
conseil départemental
parce que vous n'avez pas les
subventions n'ont pas été renouvelés que
s'est il passé depuis et différents aux
appels à projets on a parlé notamment à
du comité régional d'équitation
d'ile-de-france qui était quand s'était
porté candidat
effectivement à priori donc
ils sont toujours en lice pour pour cet
appel d'offres est donc comme je vous le
disais en fait on est en attente
effectivement du résultat en attendant
nous au niveau de l'ifc on poursuit les
missions notamment pour nous qui sont
déclarés au travers du contrat
d'objectifs et de performance donc un
contrat en fait qui est signée entre le
ministère de l'agriculture le ministère
jeunesse et sports et la tutelle du
budget et donc nous on a différentes
missions et on exerce aujourd'hui nos
missions sur le site des bréviaires
alors le haras national des bréviaires à
plusieurs missions on s'imagine que
c'est parfois juste faire des cures
déviation mais pas du tout il ya
énormément de voler jérôme lesage à vous
occuper de l'attelage il ya vraiment
voilà de la formation aussi haut niveau
au sein de la cei voilà donc au sein de
durabilité bavière et est tout vert pour
tout public
une école d'attelage où j'enseigne -
pieds mes collègues la plage à un cheval
on a une écurie de chevaux complètement
adaptés à l'enseignement et on a la
chance de
de d'enseigner en fin de de développer
cette activité dans un cadre qui est
complètement dédié un peu en fait à la
plage parce que le site fait 50 hectares
on a des désirs des infrastructures à
l'abri à en extérieur et la forêt
domaniale de
de rambouillet qui a trois minutes
hachey la plage il ya d'autres missions
il ya des missions à pédagogique à côté
encore des missions de reproduction par
rapport au choix voilà alors en fait au
niveau de la formation donc on vous a
décrit les activités d'attelage ensuite
on a réellement nous comme objectif de
former les professionnels de la filière
autour du cheval
donc on le fait son en utilisant des
ressources propres au bréviaire c'est le
cas notamment de la formation poulinage
ou sevrage où on a nos propres formateur
ou alors on fait appel aux formateurs du
réseau ifce c'est à dire des gens qui
sont dans les autres un rat et qui amène
notamment des compétences en gestion des
pâtures alimentation par exemple et
sinon on a aussi la possibilité de faire
appel aux écuyer du cadre noir sur des
formations plus spécifiques qui sont
vraiment comment complètement lié au
sport c'est à dire cso complet dressage
et ça on le fait aussi en partenariat
avec le cref pour mobiliser le site un
maximum de données beaucoup d'activité
et faire en sorte que nous
établissements publics on conçoit
aujourd'hui complètement nos missions
alors le a est aussi emblématique de
notre territoire c'est un vrai élément
du patrimoine qu'il faut conserver il
faut aussi à peut-être à développer oui
tout à fait voyons enfin le niveau
patrimonial
peut-être alors jara des bréviaires par
rapport à d'autres haras nationaux en
fait et plutôt finalement assez récent
et date de 1973 certaines
infrastructures un peu plus un peu plus
ancienne mais par contre effectivement
il porte un patrimoine un prestige
certain nous on essaie de transmettre
sein par exemple au travers aussi des
véhicules hippomobiles
on peut avoir au sein des bréviaires et
qu'on va utiliser pour des sorties un
peu de prestige par exemple lors de
visites d'élus on est amené à mouna
attelée une voiture à deux chevaux
traits par exemple des voitures
particulières qui peuvent être des
petits breaks des vagues honnête et
c'est donc on a effectivement aussi
vocation à transmettre ce type de
patrimoine
aujourd'hui en fait on transmet à la
fois du patrimoine matériel et du
patrimoine immatériel et on refait le
lien avec la formation puisque par
exemple bientôt au haras des bréviaires
on va organiser une formation autour de
la sellerie la sellerie c'est réel
savoir faire développé dans l'ensemble
des haras nationaux et nous on va faire
appel notamment au très bon formateur de
l'arast du pain qui vont venir proposer
leur formation à tous les publics et qui
tend de l'île de france alors le projet
du comité à la finalisation et de france
donc c'était justement de créer un pôle
régional d'équitation
ça pourrait ces projets pourraient
rentrer justement dans également ce
qu'il voudrait créer une maison des
genêts du cheval afin de rassembler tous
les compétences ce projet vous
conviendrait en tout cas on peut
s'associer à ce type de projet sachant
qu'ils portent exactement la dynamique
dans lesquels aujourd'hui
l'ifc eux existe c'est à dire travailler
surtout pas tout seul mais travailler en
partenariat puisque en fait l'ensemble
de ces structures donc un objectif c'est
le développement de la filière équine
notamment dans sa dimension économique
fait faire aujourd'hui qu'il y ait de
l'emploi dans la filière cheval et
qu'elle se développe vraiment de toutes
les manières possibles
est ce que cette position un peu
d'attenté on ne savait pas qui va être
repreneur c'est handicapant pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est pas un handicap 1 mais
effectivement plus tôt on aura une
visibilité un peu meilleur mieux ce sera
en attendant nous le fait qu'on ait des
missions très précises nous permet de
continuer à avancer de mobiliser une
équipe qui est actuellement d'une
douzaine d'agents propre à l'ifc eu à
développer au quotidien des missions qui
répondent exactement à la commande qu'on
a de l'état
justement quels vont être vos actualités
est ce qu'il y aura des nouveautés pour
cette année 2016 au haras malgré le fait
que l'on sait pas encore s'il va être
vendue à qui avait entrepris alors
effectivement en terme d'activité et
notamment on revient à l'attelage
puisqu'on cherche vraiment en faire la
discipline un peu moteur aujourd'hui
aussi de l'activité ifce sur le site des
bréviaires c'est l'organisation en
partenariat de la journée nationale de
l'attelage de loisir qui est une journée
portée à la base par la fédération
française d'équitation dans laquelle le
haras va cette année s'impliquer c'est
une nouveauté
et puis on a pour projet aussi il faudra
le concrétiser l'organisation d'un
concours national d'attelage plutôt à
priori mi-septembre très bien et bien
écoutez voilà si vous voulez avoir plus
d'information justement sur la taz nous
avons réalisé un reportage il n'y a pas
très longtemps n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet du haras
débrayaient des bréviaires par donc vous
y retrouverez toutes les informations
merci à vous deux est venu en patrouille
d'avoir répondu à nos questions aussi
tout autre sujet à
raison peut-être les avez-vous croisé
lors de votre trajet en bus aujourd'hui
des poètes ont investi les lignes de
transports en commun sur la journée pour
clamer textes et poésies pour le
dix-huitième printemps des poètes ski
bus a décidé de s'associer aux
itinéraire poétique pour une journée
d'animations mélanie potier pour ce
reportage
la poésie c'est quoi d'après jacques
prévert la poésie c'est ce qu'ont brève
ce qu'on imagine ce qu'on désire et ce
qui arrive souvent des passagers un peu
particulier des poètes de deux
compagnies théâtrales les profs
d'histoire et compte en bande dans les
bus saint quentinois ce jeudi pour
clamer prévert camus ou boris vian ils
prennent en otage les les voyageurs le
le conducteur aussi pour leur dire des
poèmes à leur manière alors des poèmes
qui ont été choisis principalement des
poètes du xxème siècle pour marquer le
18e printemps des poètes
mais voilà des poèmes de leur choix et
cette bande de comédiens et de
comédiennes voilà prends énormément de
plaisir apparemment à aa1 oeuvre est
comme ça dans les bus de ski bus parce
que c'est une opération qu'on a monté
avec ce qu'ils puissent tous les ans
n'affiche des poèmes dans les bus et
cette année avec jacques fournier les
itinéraires poétique de la casse qui on
a souhaité elle est un petit peu plus
loin et on a souhaité animer le réseau
faire autre chose si que tu transports
c'est aussi toujours un peu notre rôle
de lien social
onze lignes ont accueilli toute la
journée conteurs et conteuses un moyen
de sortir du train train quotidien du
métro-boulot-dodo laden le sourire dan a
le droit de vivre
ce qui me plaît c'est l'ambiance
dans le but d'un pelage au parc ombragé
de la joie de la réflexion du plaisir
avant d'aller travailler
prochain rendez vous avec la poésie le
marché de montigny le bretonneux
mercredi 16 mars
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis demain vous
retrouver wilfrid richy pour l'essentiel
de la cu quant à moi je vous retrouve
lundi pour un nouveau numéro du journal
je vous souhaite donc une très bonne
soirée et un excellent week end